En ce mois d'avril 1945,
l'armée américaine progresse
sur le territoire allemand.
Les forces d'Hitler sont en déroute.
Dans quelques jours, le 8 mai,
le Reich capitulera sans condition devant les Alliés.
Dans leur progression vers Berlin,
les GI traversent un pays écrasé par les
bombardements et rencontrent une population épuisée.
Mais ce qu'ils ne savent pas,
c'est qu'au-delà des ravages de la guerre,
ils s'apprêtent à découvrir l'inimaginable.
Une réalité, qui va marquer pour toujours
le  général Eisenhower.
Nous sommes le 12 avril 1945,
Le commandant suprême des forces alliées
est venu en personne visiter
le camp de concentration d'Ohrdurf, en Allemagne.
Ces images, il ne pourra jamais les oublier.
- C'est la sidération et le choc.
Il y a une trentaine de corps,
qui ont été laissés dehors, à l'air libre.
L'odeur est pestilentielle,
il y a des charniers.
Donc il y a quelque chose qui est au-delà
de ce que l'on peut imaginer.
Quelques jours plus tard, dans une lettre à l'un
de ses généraux, Eisenhower écrit :
"Ce que j'ai vu est au-delà de toute description,
les preuves visuelles et les témoignages de famine,
de cruauté et de bestialité étaient
d'une telle force qu'ils m'ont rendu malade."
Camps, après, camps, photographes et journalistes
sont conviés à venir découvrir de leurs yeux,
la réalité.
- C'était vraiment difficile pour les gens.
De croire à de telles atrocités.
Certains reporters n'en reviennent pas.
Le monde entier a sous les yeux les preuves
du pire crime jamais commis contre l'humanité.
Des tonnes de vêtements empilés,
des montagnes de chaussures.
Des valises par milliers, bouclées à la hâte,
pour un voyage sans retour.
Tout témoigne de l'ampleur du massacre.
Ces images provoquent une onde de choc.
Mais cette découverte est-elle réellement
une surprise pour les Alliés ?
Winston Churchill, Franklin Roosevelt
ou même Charles de Gaulle,
pouvaient-ils ignorer que, depuis 4 ans,
Hitler organisait l'extermination du peuple juif ?
Ont-ils vraiment tout mis en œuvre
pour que les criminels de guerre nazis
soient traduits devant la justice ?
Ces questions soulèvent des faits restés
longtemps dans l'ombre.
Elles touchent l'un des plus grands
tabous de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
C'est cette histoire que nous allons vous raconter.
La réalité de ce qui se passe dans les camps.
Les Alliés vont en avoir connaissance bien
plus tôt que ce que l'on peut imaginer.
Nous sommes à Varsovie, en Pologne,
en plein milieu de l'été 1940.
Au cœur de la capitale occupée par les nazis,
dans l'un de ses immeubles se tient
une réunion ultra-secrète.
Les chefs de la résistance polonaise sont en alerte,
car l'heure est grave.
Depuis quelques semaines, leur réseau
est en train d'être décimé par les Allemands.
Des milliers d'opposants politiques sont raflés
et envoyés par convois vers un camp,
qui se trouve à 300 km au sud de Varsovie.
Un camp qui porte le nom d'Auschwitz.
- On sait que c'est un camp.
Mais quelle sorte de camp ?
Ça, personne ne le sait.
Un camp aux conditions d'emprisonnement très dur.
Où les prisonniers seraient
particulièrement maltraités.
Les chefs de la lutte armée sont inquiets
pour leurs hommes enfermés là-bas.
Et chacun fait alors des suggestions.
Comment parvenir jusqu'à eux ?
Comment les contacter ?
Comment savoir ce qu'ils deviennent ?
Et parmi les résistants,
il y a un certain Witold Pilecki.
Alors que tout le monde tergiverse autour de la table,
il lui vient une idée, une idée hallucinante.
Se faire volontairement arrêter
et déporter à Auschwitz.
Et, une fois à l'intérieur, retrouver ses hommes
et organiser un soulèvement, une mutinerie.
- Pilecki, effectivement, a demandé de se voir
octroyer cette mission,
d'être enfermé dans le camp d'Auschwitz
pour y organiser l'insurrection générale
et donc la libération de ses camarades
enfermé là-bas.
La mission semble complètement folle,
mais pour ce patriote,
c'est la seule possibilité
de sauver ses compagnons.
Alors voilà, comment il va s'y prendre.
Pilecki connaît le quartier dans lequel les Allemands
s'apprêtent à organiser des rafles prochainement.
Alors, il se débrouille pour y séjourner
et il attend la prochaine vague d'arrestations.
Quelques jours plus tard,
au petit matin, sa stratégie fonctionne.
Les nazis encerclent le quartier.
Ils pénètrent dans son immeuble,
au 40 de la rue Al Wojska Polskiego.
Ils grimpent les escaliers
jusqu'à l'appartement n°7.
75 ans plus tard, nous avons retrouvé la fille
de Witold Pilecki.
Zofia a aujourd'hui 82 ans
et elle n'a rien oublié.
- Le SS a demandé s'il y avait des hommes.
Alors mon père a ouvert la porte,
il est sorti et il a été pris.
Comme il l'avait prévu, Witold Pilecki
est arrêté et déporté.
Le 21 septembre 1940, après 24 h,
entassé avec des centaines d'autres hommes,
dans un convoi de wagons à bestiaux.
Ils arrivent sur les lieux
et basculent dans un autre monde.
Sur les portes du camp,
il découvre une devise Arbeit macht frei.
Le travail rend libre.
À l'automne 1940, à Auschwitz,
c'est encore un petit camp de concentration.
Les déportés, majoritairement des prisonniers polonais,
y sont condamnés au travail forcé.
Ils sont 1800, placés sous haute surveillance,
entourés de miradors
et isolés du monde extérieur
par des kilomètres de barbelés.
Désormais Pilecki, l'infiltré, devient le matricule 4859
et il découvre avec stupéfaction,
la vie des déportés à Auschwitz.
- Mon père ne savait pas où il était.
Il se demandait si c'était un hôpital pour fou.
Tous ces cris, ses hurlements et les coups,
il les frappait, il les battait.
Il y avait des chiens, des corps écorchés.
Où suis-je ? Où suis-je entré ?
Il était choqué.
Il ne savait pas qu'il rencontrerait
de telles conditions.
Le choc était si effroyable.
Rapidement, Pilecki qui comprend qu'ici
le travail tue.
Car Auschwitz est un chantier permanent.
Les ouvriers ne sont autres
que les détenus eux-mêmes.
Une main d'œuvre réduit en esclavage.
Et quand on ne meurt pas de faim ou de froid,
Pilecki en est témoin.
On peut être la cible arbitraire des SS.
Chaque jour, des exécutions sommaires ont lieu,
au bout de cette impasse.
Le long d'un mur qu'on appellera
Le Mur des fusillés.
- Le camp de concentration,
c'est le règne de l'arbitraire.
Même s'il y a un règlement.
Le règne de la terreur
et le règne de la loi du plus fort.
Mais ce qui choque particulièrement Pilecki,
c'est que dans ce camp, il y a une population
qui est encore plus maltraitée que les autres.
Une population encore minoritaire en 1940,
mais que les SS ciblent en priorité.
Ce sont les Juifs.
- Les déportés juifs d'un camp de concentration
sont donc destinés aux tâches les plus dures,
ont des conditions de vie encore plus
difficiles que les autres.
Bref, sont de toute façon d'ores et déjà
traités différemment.
Un système de terreur généralisée qui pousse
le résistant polonais à changer ses plans.
L'urgence, c'est de faire savoir au monde
extérieur ce qui se passe à Auschwitz.
Alors, il va organiser une sorte de réseau
de résistants parmi les prisonniers.
- Il va choisir des hommes,
qu'il connaît de l'extérieur.
C'est-à-dire des membres de la résistance polonaise
et des gens qu'il a côtoyés par ailleurs
avant son entrée à Auschwitz.
Mais pour faire savoir ce qui se passe ici
au monde extérieur.
Encore faudrait-il pouvoir sortir du camp.
Or, a priori, s'évader d'Auschwitz,
c'est impossible.
Le camp est une véritable forteresse.
Le bloc des détenus est quadrillé par les SS.
Entouré par une double clôture de barbelés
et une série de miradors.
Et ceinturé par un mur de béton.
Un lieu dont on ne peut pas s'évader.
Et pourtant, Pilecki va trouver un moyen
de tenter cet exploit,
et ce grâce à des codétenus qui sont prêts
à prendre tous les risques.
Comme par exemple Kazimierz Piechowski.
À l'époque, il n'a que 19 ans
et il va mettre au point une évasion spectaculaire.
Lui et trois complices présentent leur plan
à Pilecki, lors d'une promenade dominicale.
- En fait, on faisait semblant de nous pencher.
Puis alors, on faisait mine de faire nos lacets.
Mais c'est juste pendant qu'on se penchait,
c'est à ce moment-là qu'on lui a donné l'info.
Cette mission périlleuse n'a que très peu
de chances de réussir, mais Pilecki les encourage.
Car si lui veut rester dans le camp pour continuer
d'être témoin de ce qui s'y passe.
L'évasion de Kazimierz lui permettra de faire
sortir un message, pour informer le monde extérieur.
- Pilecki disait que ça allait être difficile
de passer par le portail principal.
Mais il nous a dit d'y aller quand même.
Par sécurité, Pilecki ne veut pas
leur confier un texte écrit.
Alors, il exige que l'un des compagnons
de Kazimierz apprenne son message par cœur.
- D'abord de quoi il a écrit le message en détail.
Ensuite, il lui a dit :
Lis le bien attentivement, dix fois.
Tu lis ça dix fois !
Maintenant, est-ce que tu peux me dire sans le lire,
tout ce qu'il y a dans ce rapport ?
C'est ton rapport.
Tu l'as à présent dans la tête,
c'est ton rapport.
Tout est là, gravé dans la tête.
À midi, à l'heure du déjeuner, Kazimierz et ses trois
codétenus mettent leur stratagème à exécution.
Ils sortent tous les quatre de leurs baraquements
comme si de rien n'était.
Et se dirigent vers l'extrémité du camp.
Du côté des infrastructures nazies.
Ils se séparent alors en deux groupes.
Kazimierz et deux de ses complices se dirigent
vers l'entrepôt,
où sont stockés les uniformes des SS.
- Pour ce faire, ils avaient préparé leur intrusion
en ouvrant l'une des réserves de charbon,
en laissant ouverte une trappe
de la réserve de charbon.
Ce qui fait que, par cette réserve en sous-sol,
ils ont pu pénétrer de l'intérieur,
dans l'entrepôt de la SS.
Il leur a fallu ensuite monter au 2e étage
où se trouvait la chambre des uniformes SS.
Alors Kazimierz casse la serrure
et entre dans l'entrepôt.
Et dérobent ainsi quatre uniformes.
Pendant ce temps, le quatrième compagnon,
le mécanicien de la bande s'introduit, lui,
dans le garage des SS.
- Il était si compétent que lorsque les SS
n'arrivaient pas à réparer leur voiture.
Il la lui confiait.
Il savait tout réparer.
C'était un mécanicien hors pair.
L'homme s'installe au volant de la voiture
du commandant du camp, une Steyr 220.
Un véhicule assez puissant pour garantir
la réussite de l'évasion.
Les trois faux SS le rejoignent alors à bords.
L'équipe est prête à passer l'étape la plus délicate,
franchir le portail principal gardé par les SS.
- Ils avançaient et puis, à la toute fin semble-t-il,
puisque les grilles ne se sont pas ouvertes
et bien Piechowski dit y être allé au culot.
Il affirme avoir insulté les SS,
pour leur dire de se dépêcher d'ouvrir les grilles,
par ce qu'ils n'avaient pas que ça à faire.
Et donc ils ont obéi, ils ont ouvert les grilles.
Kazimierz et ses trois codétenus réussissent
l'impensable s'évader d'Auschwitz en plein jour.
Et, comble de l'ironie, se faire ouvrir
les portes du camp par leurs bourreaux.
En quelques minutes, ils sont loin.
Et à partir de maintenant, le message de Pilecki
entame un incroyable périple.
Confié à la résistance polonaise à Varsovie,
il va passer par l'Allemagne,
jusqu'à la zone libre en France.
Franchir la frontière espagnole et ultime étape,
rejoindre par la mer la Grande-Bretagne.
À Londres, le gouvernement polonais en exil
est en contact permanent,
avec le Premier ministre Winston Churchill.
Les autorités britanniques recevront
ainsi 8 messages que Witold Pilecki
leur fera parvenir par différents moyens.
- Les rapports de Pilecki parvenait
effectivement à Londres et aux Alliés.
C'est la meilleure preuve que son travail a
servi à quelque chose.
Et qu'il a accompli la mission
pour laquelle il était dans le camp.
Le premier des messages de Pilecki arrive à Londres
au mois de mars 1941 et voici son contenu.
Un témoignage inédit qui décrit
les conditions de vie dans le camp.
Le résistant infiltré volontaire
parle d'humiliation,
de coups de bâtons,
de nourriture insuffisante.
Quant aux SS, il les qualifie de bourreaux.
Message après message, les Britanniques découvrent
que le système concentrationnaire nazi
abat des hommes méthodiquement.
Et cela n'est qu'un début.
Les Alliés vont découvrir rapidement
que la cruauté nazie est en train de prendre
des formes jamais connues auparavant.
Nous sommes maintenant au cœur de l'été 1941.
Winston Churchill reçoit sur son bureau
un dossier confidentiel alarmant.
Il est écrit à garder sous clé
ne doit jamais sortir de ce bureau.
Ces informations proviennent
des services secrets britanniques.
Il s'agit de messages radio de l'armée allemande
qui ont été interceptés.
Et selon ces messages, depuis quelques mois,
les nazis organisent des massacres de grande ampleur
sur le front de l'Est contre les juifs.
On nous rapporte un nouveau massacre de juifs,
en Ukraine, dans les messages du 27 août 1941.
Ou encore le bataillon de police 302 revendique
avoir tué 4200 juifs sans perte de son côté.
- Les SS rapportent qu'ils ont tué 3000 juifs ici,
4000 juifs là-bas
et ils font état d'autres fusillades de juifs
et de personnalités communistes.
Les rapports s'accumulent sur son bureau et
le Premier ministre britannique comprend alors
la terrible réalité.
Au fur et à mesure qu'il progresse
en territoire soviétique.
Les nazis arrêtent et exécutent de plus en plus
les populations juives.
Ce que l'on appellera plus tard,
la Shoah par balles.
Plus d'un million de victimes.
Churchill décide alors de réagir.
Il prononce un discours à la radio
sur les ondes de la BBC.
Nous sommes le 24 août 1941 et déjà,
le Premier ministre britannique lance l'alerte.
- Depuis les invasions mongoles au XVème siècle,
il n'y a jamais eu une boucherie méthodique,
impitoyable, d'une telle ampleur.
Et ce n'est qu'un début.
Nous sommes en présence d'un crime
qui n'a pas de nom.
Un crime qui n'a pas de nom.
Des mots très forts et un message entendu
dans tout l'Occident.
Pourtant, le cri d'alarme de Churchill
trouvera peu d'écho.
- Qu'est-ce qu'il pouvait faire ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il pouvait faire pour des événements
qui se déroulaient à des milliers de kilomètres,
alors que toute l'Europe occidentale était occupée ?
Donc, c'est aussi un espèce
de raccourci mental, incroyable.
Qui est de dire, puisqu'on sait,
on peut faire quelque chose.
Mais il sait,
ils ne peuvent rigoureusement rien faire.
Il faut dire qu'en 1941,
Churchill est seul en Europe.
À l'Ouest, presque tous les gouvernements
ont capitulé devant le régime nazi.
Et à l'est, Staline et les troupes russes
viennent tout juste d'être envahi par les Allemands.
Quant aux États-Unis,
ils ne sont pas encore entrés en guerre.
Le cri d'alerte de Churchill passe donc inaperçu.
Et ce qu'il ne sait pas encore,
c'est que dans le plus grand secret,
Hitler est en train d'organiser
un projet totalement insensé.
Un crime qui dépasse l'entendement.
Le 20 janvier 1942, au sud de Berlin,
dans la petite ville de Wannsee.
15 hauts responsables du troisième Reich se réunissent
en toute discrétion dans cette villa très chic.
Leur but mettre au point ensemble les aspects
pratiques d'un programme ultra-secret.
- Pour pouvoir déporter et assassiner les juifs,
il faut pratiquement
que toutes les administrations nazies
mettent la main à la pâte.
Et ça, c'est validé.
Pendant 2 h, ils discutent de logistique
avec pour seul objectif
l'élimination de tous les juifs d'Europe.
Pour cela, ils les ont recensés pays par pays.
Au total 11 millions de personnes.
Puis, ils mettent en place les modalités
de leur arrestation et de leur transport
vers les lieux d'extermination.
Car ce qu'ils veulent,
c'est accélérer les cadences.
Parmi les participants, il y a le très zélé,
Adolf Eichmann,
l'un des hauts responsables des affaires juives
auprès du régime nazi.
- Adolf Eichmann rédige ensuite
le compte rendu de la réunion.
Ils fument des cigares, ils boivent du cognac
et c'est une réunion normale.
Ils prennent toutefois quelques précautions.
Des mots comme tuer, assassiner ou exterminer
ne sont jamais employés.
À la place, ils préfèrent
une expression plus abstraite.
Endlösung der judenfrage, littéralement,
la solution finale de la question juive.
Leur plan doit à tout prix rester confidentiel.
- Ils ont très probablement conscience,
qu'ils transgressent, quelque chose
et que cette transgression,
c'est-à-dire l'assassinat...
d'hommes, de vieillards,
de femmes, d'enfants, de bébés,
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas admissible.
En principe, seul Hitler et sa garde
rapprochée sont au courant.
Pourtant, l'information va filtrer et
c'est un homme de l'intérieur du troisième Reich
qui va la transmettre aux Alliés.
Un homme qui a joué un rôle capital
et dont l'identité est pourtant restée
l'un des plus grands secrets
de l'histoire contemporaine.
Pour percer le mystère,
nous partons pour les États-Unis,
direction sa capitale, Washington.
C'est ici que se trouvent ceux qui ont permis
de découvrir le nom de ce héros inconnu.
Il s'agit de deux historiens,
Walter Laqueur et Richard Breitman,
deux universitaires de renom,
qui ont mené l'enquête.
- Je pense qu'il était beaucoup plus important
que Chandler.
Parce que Chandler a fait de grandes choses.
Il a sauvé des milliers de personnes,
mais ce messager, lui,
voulait en sauver des millions.
C'était un héros ignoré.
Ce qui les a mis sur la trace de cet homme,
c'est ce document,
un télégramme daté du 29 août 1942.
Il est adressé au Congrès juif mondial
à New York et il dévoile le projet des nazis.
"Reçu rapport alarmant concernant plan discuté
au quartier général du Führer,
pour exterminer d'un seul coup tous les juifs
des pays contrôlés par l'Allemagne,
soit trois et demi à 4 millions de personnes.
L'expéditeur de ces télégrammes est anonyme.
Il n'est désigné que par quelques mots.
Un informateur connu comme étant proche
des hautes autorités allemandes
et dont les rapports sont considérés comme fiables.
Personne aux États-Unis,
y compris aux plus hauts sommets de l'administration,
ne connaît sa véritable identité.
- C'est le plus grand secret de l'Holocauste.
Richard Breitman et Walter Laqueur,
les deux historiens américains
ne sont parvenus à résoudre l'énigme
du mystérieux informateur,
qu'après des années de recherches.
- J'exultais.
C'est le plus grand défi que j'ai eu à relever
dans toute ma carrière.
Et c'est sûrement la plus grande satisfaction
que j'ai jamais eue.
Une incroyable histoire qui démarre en Allemagne,
en Silésie, dans la ville de Breslau.
C'est ici que se trouve celui qui va trahir Hitler.
Il s'appelle Edward Schulte deux.
Schulte, c'est un grand bourgeois.
Il est marié et père de deux garçons.
Un chasseur qui passe ses week-ends en forêt
et ses soirées en compagnie du gratin de la région.
Sa prospérité, il la doit à ses usines.
Il est à la tête de l'une des plus grandes
fabriques minières d'Allemagne.
Il emploie plus de 30 000 personnes.
Son entreprise produit du zinc,
un matériau nécessaire à la fabrication de munitions,
un secteur clé en temps de guerre.
Voilà pourquoi il côtoie régulièrement
les officiels du régime nazi.
- Il faisait partie d'un petit cercle
de gens importants.
Ils devaient connaître des officiels.
Il ne les voyait pas tous les jours,
mais il a dû prendre part à d'importantes réunions.
Nous avons retrouvé un homme qui se souvient bien,
d'Edouard Schulte.
C'est son petit fils, Roy.
- Mon grand-père était très grand, très musclé.
C'était un homme en pleine santé.
Quand il entrait dans une pièce, on le remarquait.
Il était sûr de lui.
C'était un extraverti qui connaissait beaucoup de gens,
qui aimaient parler et refaire le monde.
Mais Schulte joue un double jeu.
Car en réalité, il déteste le régime nazi.
Il déteste Adolf Hitler.
Il ne souhaite qu'une chose,
la chute du troisième Reich.
- Il pensait que c'étaient des voyous
qui mèneraient l'Allemagne à sa perte.
Edward Schulte a des amis juifs,
qu'il voit en secret.
Il entretient même une relation intime
qui, dans ce contexte, peut lui coûter très cher.
- Mon grand-père avait une maîtresse à Zurich
pendant que sa femme restait en Allemagne.
Et cette maîtresse était juive.
Doris, une passion,
qu'il vit dans le plus grand secret.
Car si le régime nazi l'apprenait,
ils seraient tous les deux en grand danger.
Alors, au nom de ses convictions politiques,
dans l'ombre, Edward Schulte est devenu
un informateur au service des Alliés.
Dès qu'il en a l'occasion, il fait parvenir des
informations stratégiques à Londres et à Washington.
Et c'est ainsi qu'il va dévoiler
le plus criminel des projets nazis, aux Américains.
Dans son entreprise, il emploie un certain,
Otto Pfitzner.
Un homme très introduit auprès des milieux nazis,
auquel Schulte soutire
à son insu des informations précieuses.
- Personne ne savait, et surtout pas Pfitzner,
que Schulte détestait les nazis.
En fait, Schulte poussait même Pfitzner à s'engager.
"Tu veux postuler au bureau nazi
de l'économie de guerre ?
Vas-y, ça sera bien pour l'entreprise."
Et Pfitzner se vante d'avoir accès
à des informations de haute valeur.
Ainsi, au mois de juillet 1942,
il affirme devant son patron avoir eu
connaissance d'une décision ultra-secrète,
en provenance directe du QG d'Hitler.
Schulte va alors habilement le manipuler
pour en savoir plus.
Schulte a dû lui dire : Tu ne peux pas vraiment
savoir ce qui se passe au quartier général d'Hitler.
Et Pfitzner a dû lui répondre.
"Mais si, bien sûr, je sais.
Et tu veux un exemple.
Voilà ce qui se dit au quartier général d'Hitler.
Ils élaborent un plan pour tuer
entre 3,5 et 4 millions de juifs.
Un plan pour exterminer jusqu'à 4 millions de juifs.
L'information est difficile à croire.
Mais Edward Schulte comprend aussitôt qu'il s'agit
d'une décision sans précédent dans l'histoire.
- On peut imaginer ce qu'il a dû ressentir.
Quand il a eu la formation que 3,5
à 4 millions d'innocents allaient être tués.
On peut imaginer la pression.
Que puis-je faire ?
Que devrais-je faire ?
Quels risques dois-je prendre ?
Schulte décide d'informer les puissances alliées
pour tenter d'éviter que des millions d'innocents
ne soient massacrés.
- Dès qu'il a appris cela,
il est monté dans un train pour Zurich,
avec cette information.
Il avait des détails, il avait des dates,
il avait des lieux et des renseignements
sur la technique de gazage employée
pour tuer ces gens.
Le 29 juillet 1942, Schulte profite d'un voyage
d'affaires comme il en fait régulièrement.
Puis, il en profite pour traverser l'Europe
et se rendre dans un territoire neutre, la Suisse.
Il ne veut surtout pas attirer l'attention.
Alors, il ne déroge pas à ses habitudes.
À Zurich, il passe la soirée avec Doris,
sa maîtresse.
Mais il reste muet sur le vrai motif de sa visite.
Le lendemain en revanche, il s'éclipse
pour un rendez-vous extrêmement discret.
Officiellement, c'est un rendez-vous d'affaires.
En réalité, c'est une entrevue
avec l'une de ses connaissances juives,
un grand banquier en qui il a toute confiance.
Un homme qui a des relais outre-Atlantique.
Et avant de lui délivrer son terrible message,
Schulte pose une condition.
- Je vais te dire quelque chose, mais je veux
ta parole d'honneur,
que mon nom ne sera jamais révélé.
Le banquier lui promet
qu'il préservera son anonymat.
Alors, Schulte délivre son information.
- Il lui a dit ensuite que la décision de tuer
tous les juifs d'Europe avait été prise.
Et que ça commençait immédiatement.
Et que pour cela, ils utilisaient du gaz.
Il lui a dit que ces actes terribles
avaient commencé et continuaient.
C'est ainsi que le fameux télégramme
est envoyé à New York
et arrive sur le bureau du représentant américain
du Congrès juif mondial, le rabbin Stephen Wise.
Et le 24 novembre 1942, Stephen Wise convoque
tous les médias américains,
à une grande conférence de presse.
Devant un parterre de journalistes,
le rabbin annonce que les nazis déportent
massivement des juifs en Pologne,
en vue d'une extermination de grande ampleur.
C'est la première fois qu'une telle information
est rendue publique.
Le problème, c'est qu'elle ne va pas du tout déclencher
le séisme médiatique qu'Edouard Schulte espérait.
Le lendemain, le New York Times titre à la une,
sur les dernières nouvelles
du front de l'Est et de Stalingrad.
Pour lire l'information tonitruante de Schulte,
il faut ouvrir le journal et se rendre en page 10.
Coincée entre deux photos.
L'information se résume à une simple dépêche,
cinq paragraphes courts et factuels,
dans lesquels on peut lire
qu'une campagne d'extermination a lieu
dans les territoires européens
occupés par les nazis.
La réalité, c'est que l'information semble
si ahurissante que personne ne la trouve crédible.
- Il y a beaucoup de gens
qui trouvent tout ça farfelu.
Ils trouvent ça tellement exagéré, qu'ils pensent
que les organisations juives doivent en rajouter.
Ils ont du mal à imaginer que des êtres humains
puissent faire ça à d'autres êtres humains.
Mais désormais, l'information est publique.
Les gouvernements alliés ne peuvent plus l'ignorer.
D'autant que maintenant, les preuves s'accumulent.
Les alliés reçoivent d'autres informations
qui recoupent celles de Schulte.
Comme notamment le rapport
d'un autre résistant polonais.
Le rapport de Jan Karski,
qui lui aussi confirme en novembre 1942,
qu'un massacre organisé de Juifs
est en cours en Pologne.
Alors quelques jours plus tard,
le 17 décembre 1942.
Les représentants des Alliés, dont Churchill,
Roosevelt, Staline et même le général de Gaulle,
se mettent d'accord.
Il rédige ensemble une déclaration qui dresse
le sinistre bilan de l'étendue du massacre.
"Dans tous les pays occupés par l'Allemagne,
les Juifs sont transportés par train
dans des conditions d'horreur
et de brutalité vers l'Europe de l'Est.
En Pologne, qui est devenue
le principal abattoir nazi.
Le nombre de ces sanglantes cruautés
s'élève à des centaines de milliers d'innocents.
Hommes, femmes et enfants.
Les gouvernements susmentionnés condamnent
de la manière la plus ferme possible
cette politique bestiale
d'extermination de sang-froid.
Les responsables de ces crimes
ne resteront pas impunis."
- Les gouvernements voulaient montrer
aux populations concernées,
qu'ils faisaient quelque chose au sujet
des massacres de masse, notamment de juifs.
Mais l'antisémitisme était si fort.
Et personne ne voulait donner l'impression
qu'il était plus préoccupé,
par les massacres de juifs que par l'idée
de gagner la guerre le plus rapidement
et le plus efficacement possible.
Les alliés ne dépassent donc pas le stade
de la déclaration.
Pour qu'ils réfléchissent enfin à une intervention.
Il va falloir encore des mois.
Et les appels à l'aide d'hommes de l'ombre,
notamment de l'un d'entre eux qui assiste
à l'accélération de ce massacre depuis l'intérieur
et qui prend tous les risques pour les alerter.
Cet homme, c'est Witold Pilecki.
Car depuis maintenant 2 ans, l'infiltré polonais
survit toujours dans l'enfer du camp d'Auschwitz.
De l'intérieur, il a assisté à la mise en place
concrète de la solution finale.
Les nazis sont passés à une phase
d'industrialisation de la mort.
Ils ont agrandi à Auschwitz
et construit un deuxième camp.
Le camp de Birkenau.
Quatre complexes de chambres à gaz et de fours
crématoires fonctionnent désormais à plein régime.
- Nulle part ailleurs qu'à Auschwitz,
on a eu cette rationalisation de l'assassinat.
En 1943, Pilecki voit chaque jour affluer
des convois de juifs venus de toute l'Europe.
Ceux qui ne sont pas jugés aptes à travailler
sont envoyés directement aux chambres à gaz.
Les Allemands tuent jusqu'à
4000 personnes par jour.
- Dans ces messages, il disait que des convois
entiers étaient menés vers la liquidation.
Il demandait une réaction des alliés,
dans les messages qui leur envoyaient.
Il faut dire que Pilecki s'est donné beaucoup
de mal pour transmettre des messages auprès des Alliés,
notamment grâce à des ouvriers polonais
qui travaillent sur le camp,
mais qui vivent à l'extérieur.
Alors le résistant ne comprend pas
que personne ne réagisse.
- Londres dormait.
Au moins, s'il nous avait dit,
attendez 6 mois, 1 an, mais ils n'ont rien dit.
Le silence ! Pas un mot.
Aucune réponse.
Pilecki qui ne supportent plus
cette absence de réaction.
Il finit même par douter que ses messages
parviennent bien jusqu'aux Alliés.
Alors, il va décider de s'évader à son tour
pour porter le message lui-même.
- Il se disait : Je dois aller
jusqu'à Varsovie pour voir ce qui se passe.
Voir pourquoi on ne peut pas délivrer le camp.
Pour s'évader, Pilecki va mettre au point
un plan particulièrement ingénieux.
Il se débrouille pour se faire embaucher
avec d'autres prisonniers,
à la boulangerie des Allemands.
Elle se situe à 2 km à l'extérieur du camp.
Et le 26 avril 1943, pendant la nuit de Pâques
et alors que beaucoup de SS sont en congé.
Witold Pilecki et deux de ses complices boulangers
vont profiter d'un moment,
où la surveillance se relâche.
- Bien après minuit, lorsque le pain est enfourné.
Les prisonniers pouvaient se reposer un peu.
Les SS étaient occupés à leurs affaires.
Pilecki et ses deux amis ont donc commencé leurs
tentatives d'évasion.
En quelques minutes, ils coupent les fils des alarmes
et dévissent la barre de fer qui protège la porte.
- Après avoir ouvert la porte rouillée.
La liberté était devant eux.
Liberté encore pleine de danger.
Mais il était à l'extérieur des barbelés.
Après 947 jours de détention,
Pilecki retrouve la liberté.
Sur cette photo, il pose, amaigri,
mais tout sourire,
entre ses deux complices d'évasion.
Il est enfin sorti de l'enfer d'Auschwitz
et il n'a plus qu'une obsession,
témoigner de ce qu'il a vu.
- C'était un génocide, un effroyable génocide.
Il fallait à tout prix
faire quelque chose avec ce camp.
Le délivrer tant que les gens étaient
encore vivants.
Car l'extermination était si énorme.
Des milliers de personnes mouraient chaque jour.
De retour à Varsovie, ils commencent alors la rédaction
d'un rapport sur ces 2 ans et demi de captivité.
Ce rapport d'une vingtaine de pages est connu
sous le nom de rapport W.
Nous nous le sommes procuré.
Nous le traduisons ici pour la première fois,
en français.
Dans ces 20 pages, sans connaître les tenants
et les aboutissants du projet nazi,
Pilecki décrit avec précision,
ce qu'on lui a rapporté,
mais aussi ce qu'il a vu de ses propres yeux.
Des passages entiers décrivent notamment
la ruse des nazis, pour éviter la panique des femmes
qui sont conduites à la mort.
" Ils leur donneront du savon et une serviette,
et ils croiront aller prendre une douche.
Parfois, ils ne font même plus cette comédie.
Une fenêtre du toit s'ouvrira, d'où tombera du gaz."
Pilecki fournit aussi des informations
sur la capacité gigantesque des fours crématoires.
"On a calculé que le travail
de deux tours de service,
avec crémation de deux cadavres par poste,
permet de brûler plus ou moins
5 millions de cadavres,
dans deux fours crématoires par an.
Pilecki envoie son rapport aux résistants
de Varsovie qui le transmettent
au gouvernement polonais en exil à Londres.
- Les autorités de Varsovie ont estimé qu'il fallait
envoyer l'ensemble du rapport à Londres.
Et il a été transmis aux autorités britanniques.
Le rapport W s'ajoute ainsi à tous les éléments
déjà reçus par les Alliés,
et il confirme que l'extermination des Juifs
par les nazis est bien une réalité.
Alors quelques mois plus tard,
au printemps 1944, l'idée d'une intervention
pour empêcher ou au moins freiner le massacre
va enfin prendre corps.
Des organisations juives proposent que,
pour stopper net l'arrivée de nouveaux convois,
les Alliés bombardent les rails,
qui mènent au camp.
Mais cette option va être rapidement écartée.
- Cela n'avait pas de sens, de demander
aux militaires de bombarder les voies ferrées.
Les Allemands réparaient les rails facilement.
Ils les réparaient en quelques jours,
parfois en quelques heures.
On ne pouvait pas demander aux pilotes de partir
pour une mission aussi dangereuse,
alors qu'elle n'aurait pas eu d'effet tangible.
Une seconde option va alors séduire
le Premier ministre britannique Winston Churchill.
Détruire le cœur du dispositif en larguant
des bombes directement sur les chambres à gaz
et les fours crématoires.
- Churchill a rédigé un mémo au secrétaire
d'État à la Guerre.
Il lui a écrit :
Prenez toutes les forces aériennes
que vous voulez et dites
que j'y suis personnellement favorable.
Donc, en principe, Churchill y était favorable.
Malgré l'appui de Churchill, le bombardement
à Auschwitz ne sera jamais vraiment considéré
comme une option sérieuse
par les états-majors alliés.
D'abord pour une raison toute simple,
c'est qu'à l'époque les moyens militaires
manquent cruellement de précision.
- L'expression bombardement de précision
est contradictoire.
Parfois, les bombes tombent à des kilomètres
de la cible et si vous ne touchez pas
les chambres à gaz et les fours crématoires.
Vous tuez simplement des prisonniers
et vous n'obtenez aucun résultat.
- Plus de 100 000 prisonniers vivaient
dans des baraquements à côté des fours crématoires.
Donc, la probabilité de massacrer des prisonniers
et de ne pas toucher
les fours crématoires était importante.
Mais il y a surtout une autre raison.
Depuis des mois, en réalité,
les Alliés ont fait leur choix.
Les camps sont loin d'être une priorité.
- La ligne officielle consistait à dire
que la meilleure chose que l'on pouvait faire,
c'était de concentrer tous les efforts
pour gagner la guerre
et ainsi sauver le plus de vies possible.
Pourtant, au printemps 44, les avions alliés
vont bien aller au sud de la Pologne
et frapper des usines allemandes
qui se trouvent à seulement 5 km d'Auschwitz.
Frapper les chambres à gaz du camp d'extermination
était donc matériellement et humainement possible.
Et aujourd'hui, certains historiens
estiment que bombarder les camps
aurait permis de sauver des vies.
- On peut imaginer qu'il aurait pu sauver
des dizaines de milliers de personnes.
- Et même s'il n'avait pu en sauver que 100,
cela en aurait valu la peine.
Le pire, c'est que les derniers mois de la guerre
sont aussi ceux ou la cadence d'extermination
va atteindre son maximum.
Entre mai et juillet 1944,
soit seulement en trois mois,
420 000 Juifs sont morts gazés.
Quand l'Armée rouge libère les premiers camps
d'extermination en Pologne,
elle prend la mesure de l'ampleur du massacre.
En cinq ans, des millions d'hommes
et de femmes ont été assassinés.
6 millions de juifs ont été exterminés.
Les alliés savaient, mais ils n'ont rien fait
pour arrêter la machine de mort nazie.
Alors que dans l'ombre,
des hommes prenaient des risques insensés,
pour que le monde sache
ce qui se passait dans les camps.
Des hommes dont le destin a été à jamais bouleversé.
Après s'être battu contre les nazis,
le résistant polonais Witold Pilecki
va affronter un nouvel ennemi après la guerre.
Le pouvoir communiste mis en place
par les Soviétiques en Pologne.
Arrêté et jugé comme opposant au régime,
Witold Pilecki a été fusillé en mai 1948.
Quant à Edward Schulte, lui,
il a dû fuir l'Allemagne dès 1943.
Les nazis avaient découvert qu'il informait
secrètement les Alliés.
Il s'est installé en Suisse,
où il a épousé sa maîtresse Doris.
Il est mort à Zurich en janvier 1966,
à l'âge de 75 ans.
L'un comme l'autre sont des héros,
des hommes qui ont tout tenté
pour que la vérité triomphe.
Mais alors, si les alliés n'ont pas empêché les crimes,
vont-ils au moins punir les criminels ?
Les responsables du génocide seront-ils arrêtés,
pour répondre de leurs actes ?
En apparence, quand on regarde les images
des actualités de l'époque,
on pourrait croire que les alliés ont fait le maximum
pour juger les nazis.
Mais vous allez voir que les apparences
sont parfois trompeuses.
À Nuremberg, en Allemagne, le 20 novembre 1945
s'ouvre l'un des plus grands procès de l'histoire.
Sur le banc des accusés,
près de 200 hauts responsables nazis.
Parmi eux, tout sourire, Hermann Goering,
numéro deux du régime.
Le procès est hautement symbolique.
Il va durer plus d'un an.
Les caméras du monde entier couvrent l'événement.
- Le procès du siècle prend de l'ampleur.
Sur les 21 accusés, il manque le principal :
le génie diabolique, Adolf Hitler.
Les mots et les actions des chefs nazis seront utilisés
contre eux afin de les condamner pour leurs crimes.
Les charges retenues sont à la hauteur des
atrocités commises.
Le terme de crime contre l'humanité est employé,
pour la première fois par une cour de justice.
Sur 200 accusés, 37 seront condamnés à mort
et exécutés dans les jours qui suivent,
par pendaison.
Mais si justice a été rendue pour ces hauts
responsables, en réalité sur le banc des accusés,
ils devraient être bien plus nombreux.
Dans ces documents, les alliés ont identifié
les criminels de guerre nazis.
Sur plusieurs centaines de pages,
ils les ont répertoriés, un par un.
Et la liste compte au total plus de 30 000 noms.
- Les SS, les militaires, tous ceux
qui sont recherchés pour des crimes de guerre.
Des crimes contre les soldats alliés
ou contre les juifs sont dans cette liste.
Parmi tous ces noms, certains résonnent
encore aujourd'hui, comme Adolf Eichmann,
le grand organisateur des camps de la mort.
Le docteur Josef Mengele,
médecin-chef à Auschwitz,
qui se livrait à des expériences médicales
sur les déportés.
Ou encore Klaus Barbie, surnommé le boucher de Lyon.
Le chef de la Gestapo responsable de l'arrestation
et de la déportation de centaines de Juifs.
30 000 nazis listés et pour chacun d'entre eux
une affectation.
Camp de Mauthausen, Dachau ou encore Auschwitz.
Est mentionné également le crime qui leur est reproché.
Meurtres et tortures reviennent le plus souvent.
Si la quasi-totalité d'entre eux sont absents
aux différents procès organisés par les Alliés,
c'est parce que ces criminels n'ont désormais
plus qu'un objectif,
échapper à la justice.
Pour y parvenir, de nombreux nazis vont avoir
recours à des filières organisées.
Bénéficier en secret,
de l'appui d'institutions officielles.
Et profiter de complicités au-dessus de tout soupçon.
- Environ 150 000 personnes ont commis
des crimes de guerre sous le 3ᵉ Reich.
Seuls 50 000 ont été arrêtés.
Alors, qu'est-il arrivé aux 100 000 autres ?
Ils n'ont pas pu disparaître !
Il y a eu en fait un réseau d'exfiltration organisé
pour échapper à la justice.
On appelle ça : la route des rats.
Des réseaux ultra-sophistiqués qui vont permettre
à des milliers de nazis de fuir loin, très loin.
Des cavales qui vont les mener parfois
à l'autre bout du monde,
mais qui commencent...
En pleine campagne allemande.
Nous sommes à l'été 45, au nord du pays,
dans une ferme comme celle-ci,
un agriculteur coule à l'époque
des jours tranquilles.
Il s'appelle Friedrich Neumann.
Mais contrairement aux apparences,
cet homme est loin d'être un simple paysan.
Tout cela n'est qu'une couverture.
Ce fermier est en réalité un officier SS.
Son vrai nom Rudolf von Alvensleben.
L'un des patrons de la police en Ukraine,
qui a sur les mains,
le sang de près de 5000 victimes civiles
exécutées par balles.
Des Juifs et des Tsiganes.
Son nom apparaît d'ailleurs, sur le fameux listing
des criminels de guerre.
Il est l'un des nazis les plus recherchés.
- Pendant la guerre, c'était un haut responsable SS,
en charge de la police et de la sécurité.
Il était l'un des proches collaborateurs
d'Himmler et en même temps,
il vient d'une grande famille aristocrate.
À tous les niveaux,
c'est donc un nazi de très haut rang.
C'est vraiment un personnage important.
90% des criminels de guerre à l'époque
se terrent à la campagne.
Souvent, ils ont pu ainsi rester incognitos
dans leur propre pays,
sans se faire prendre et même vivre paisiblement.
Mais parfois, ils ont dû changer leurs plans.
Et c'est ce qui va arriver à Rudolf von Alvensleben.
Le 2 août 1946, Rudolf voit débarquer
chez lui des personnes qu'il n'attendait pas.
Une Jeep avec à l'intérieur des enquêteurs
venus l'interroger.
Car depuis des mois, des centaines de soldats,
des troupes alliées ratissent tout le pays.
Même dans les endroits les plus reculés.
Porte-à-porte, check-points.
Tout le monde est contrôlé et arrêté au moindre doute.
Et justement, Rudolf von Alvensleben va éveiller
les soupçons des enquêteurs,
lorsqu'ils débarquent dans sa ferme.
Il se fait arrêter pour être emmené
dans un camp de prisonniers comme celui-ci.
Où sont envoyés des milliers de suspects.
Et il va subir un interrogatoire serré.
Sur cette fiche que nous avons retrouvée,
il soutient qu'il s'appelle bien Friedrich Neumann.
Il affirme qu'il est fluchtling,
c'est-à-dire réfugié de guerre.
Et que sa profession actuelle est bien,
landwirt, en français, fermier.
Mais face à lui, il va avoir affaire
à un enquêteur suspicieux,
car son comportement ne colle pas
du tout avec ses réponses.
Il a d'ailleurs plutôt des allures d'aristocrates
que de simples paysans.
- Il y avait quelque chose dans son allure,
sa façon de parler, dans son comportement.
C'est quelqu'un qui était très sûr de lui.
Tout cela lui a fait penser que cet homme
ne venait pas du petit peuple.
Il était beaucoup plus que cela.
Et cela a éveillé les  soupçons.
L'enquêteur le soupçonne même
d'être un gros poisson.
Ordre est alors donné de le surveiller de très près.
La cavale de Von Alvensleben aurait dû s'arrêter là,
dans un camp.
Mais en réalité, elle ne fait que commencer.
- L'enquêteur a dit à ses collègues :
Assurez-vous que le garde,
le mettre bien à l'isolement !
Parce qu'il avait des doutes sur Von Alvensleben.
Et malheureusement, quand l'enquêteur est revenu,
la première chose que son collègue lui a dit,
c'est :
Oh ! Von Alvensleben est parti.
Eh oui, le prisonnier s'est échappé,
profitant du chaos ambiant
d'un camp organisé à la hâte.
Il a pris la place d'un blessé dans une ambulance
en partance pour l'hôpital.
Mais Von Alvensleben le sait,
il est maintenant découvert.
Il lui faut quitter l'Allemagne et au plus vite.
Il va alors parcourir des kilomètres
et se fondre dans la masse des millions
de réfugiés qui sillonnent le pays.
- Dans le chaos de l'Europe, dans les décombres,
dans tout ce désordre.
Tous ces gens qui courent dans tous les sens.
C'est très simple de se faire passer
pour quelqu'un d'autre et de se cacher.
Ça a beaucoup aidé les nazis en fuite.
Mais où aller exactement ?
C'est toute la question pour les nazis en cavale.
Car quelle que soit la direction, c'est l'impasse.
Toute l'Allemagne est encerclée.
Au nord, il y a la barrière de la mer.
À l'est, les Soviétiques procèdent
à des exécutions expéditives.
Et à l'ouest, les alliés ont massé leurs troupes.
Reste alors une option, une toute petite brèche
au sud du pays, à 150 km de la frontière.
Niché dans les Alpes, entre l'Autriche et l'Italie.
C'est une région paisible,
où les nazis vont pouvoir trouver refuge
et même obtenir le sésame,
pour échapper à la traque des alliés.
Cet endroit, c'est le Sud-Tyrol, une petite région
qui possède un statut très particulier à cette époque.
Car dans cette période, où les frontières de l'Europe
sont en train d'être redessinées.
Les alliés n'ont pas encore tranché sur son sort.
Conséquence ?
Les habitants du Sud-Tyrol n'ont pas de nationalité,
ils sont apatrides.
Une anomalie administrative,
qui n'a duré que quelques mois,
mais dont de nombreux nazis vont profiter.
Et parmi eux, par exemple, Von Alvensleben.
Il va se rendre sur place et il va trouver
bon accueil, car beaucoup de Tyroliens
sont germanophones et n'ont jamais caché
leurs affinités avec le régime d'Hitler.
- Ici, on ne pose pas beaucoup de questions.
Vous allez trouver beaucoup de gens
qui vont vous aider.
Vous avez besoin d'un lieu où rester,
rester à Bolzano.
Dans la ville ou bien là-haut dans la montagne.
C'est un endroit très, très accueillant,
pour un nazi.
Quant aux autorités administratives locales,
elles se montrent, elles aussi, bienveillantes.
Elles ne font aucune difficulté pour délivrer
de nouveaux papiers d'identité.
Une couverture toute neuve pour les nazis en fuite.
C'est ainsi que Rudolf Von Alvensleben devient
officiellement Kremhart Teodoro.
Il s'invente même un nouveau passé.
Il est maintenant d'origine italienne,
son père s'appelle lui aussi Teodoro.
Sa mère, Anna.
Une nouvelle identité totalement légale.
Et surtout, l'officier SS bénéficie
du fameux statut d'apatride.
Un détail essentiel, car cela va lui permettre
d'obtenir facilement un titre de voyage.
C'est-à-dire une sorte de passeport
pour quitter l'Europe.
- Le Sud-Tyrol était une région importante
pour tous ces gens.
Il y avait des facilités administratives
pour peut-être obtenir des papiers d'identité
ou un document de voyage.
Tout ce qui leur permettra
de continuer leur fuite.
Et pour décrocher le fameux passeport,
les nazis vont avoir recours
à des réseaux d'une efficacité redoutable.
Avec à leur tête des hommes haut placés
et à priori au-dessus de tout soupçon.
Nous sommes à Rome, au lendemain de la guerre.
L'Italie, l'un des premiers pays libérés,
par les Alliés.
L'Italie tourne alors tout juste
la page du fascisme.
Pourtant, au cœur même de sa capitale,
il y a une institution vers laquelle
les nazis vont se tourner.
Une institution dont certains membres sont
antinazis, tandis que d'autres, à l'inverse,
vont organiser la fuite des criminels de guerre.
Cette institution, c'est l'Église catholique,
car au sein même du Vatican,
il y a de hauts responsables ecclésiastiques
qui n'ont pas pour seule conviction
celle de la religion.
Comme par exemple l'évêque Alois Hudal,
d'origine autrichienne.
Monseigneur Hudal est également
un grand admirateur du régime nazi.
- Il était de notoriété publique,
qu'il était le plus proche ami des nazis,
à l'intérieur du Vatican.
Avant la guerre, Alois Hudal a même écrit un livre
dont le titre affiche clairement ses positions.
Les fondements du national socialisme.
Un livre dans lequel il essaie de réconcilier
le catholicisme et le nazisme.
Il va même jusqu'à adresser un exemplaire
à Adolf Hitler qui dédicace.
Au Siegfried de la grandeur allemande,
comparant ainsi le Führer au fameux prince guerrier
invulnérable dans la mythologie.
- C'était un membre d'honneur du parti.
Et un supporteur ardent du 3ᵉ Reich.
Il roulait dans Rome avec un drapeau du Grand Reich.
Du moins jusqu'à l'arrivée des Alliés.
Mais alors que le Reich vient de tomber,
Alois Hudal va utiliser tout son pouvoir
pour aider les fugitifs nazis.
Il va leur obtenir des passeports
en bonne et due forme
et les aider ainsi à partir très loin.
Tout s'organise ici, au 20 de la via della Pace,
la rue de la Paix, à Rome.
Nous sommes au siège de l'église allemande
dirigée par Alois Hudal.
Est également basée ici l'une des branches
de la Commission pontificale d'assistance.
Créée à la fin de la guerre,
pour accueillir les réfugiés.
- L'Église catholique était très importante
pour ces réfugiés.
En arrivant en Italie, ils ne parlaient pas
la langue et il n'avait pas de papiers.
Il n'avait pas d'argent,
et ils avaient parfois leur famille avec eux.
Alors que faire ?
Il commençait à chercher des contacts
et le premier, pour la plupart d'entre eux,
c'était l'Église catholique.
Mais cette commission, dont il est l'un des patrons,
Hudal ne va pas hésiter à en détourner la fonction,
car l'évêque n'aide pas seulement les miséreux.
Il porte également une attention toute particulière
à d'autres types de réfugiés,
des criminels nazis,
qu'il va même accueillir chez lui.
- Parfois, Hudal cachait des Allemands chez lui.
Sinon, il y avait aussi d'autres petits appartements
partout dans Rome.
Où ces gens pouvaient se cacher.
Et quand d'importants criminels de guerre
nazis arrivaient, Hudal les accueillait
et les saluait par leur vrai nom,
il savait qui ils étaient.
Et c'est au nom du Vatican,
avec les moyens du Saint-Siège,
qu'Alois Hudal va aider les nazis en fuite.
Comme le prouve ce document,
que nous nous sommes procurés.
Il s'agit d'une lettre rédigée
par la commission pontificale,
avec en entête les armoiries du Vatican.
Elle est datée du 26 juillet 1948
et il y est demandé de courtoisement délivrer
le passeport à la personne suivante,
Otto Pape, de nationalité apatride.
La demande est adressée à la Croix-Rouge internationale.
Si cela peut paraître, aujourd'hui, surprenant.
À l'époque, l'Europe est dans un tel chaos
que l'association humanitaire se voit confier
la mission de fournir des passeports aux réfugiés,
qui veulent émigrer.
Mais avant de délivrer le précieux document,
la Croix-Rouge impose plusieurs conditions,
être apatride et fournir soit un témoin,
qui confirme l'identité du demandeur,
soit une caution morale.
Alors quoi de mieux qu'une lettre comme celle-ci,
avec la caution du Vatican,
représenté par un évêque comme Alois Hudal ?
C'est la garantie absolue de décrocher un passeport.
- La cheffe de la Croix-Rouge locale raconte
qu'elle donnait à Hudal tout ce qu'il demandait.
C'était un évêque, après tout !
Bien sûr qu'elle allait croire un homme d'Église.
Il lui disait quel nom mettre
et à quelle date le signer et elle le faisait.
Elle ne pensait pas à mal, elle !
Et résultat, le jour même, la Croix-Rouge délivre
le passeport demandé au dénommé Otto Pape.
Mais cette Otto Pape à la moustache bien soignée
n'est pas franchement un réfugié comme les autres.
C'est le nazi le plus recherché d'Italie.
Son vrai nom,
est Erich Priebke, capitaine SS,
officier de la Gestapo à Rome,
il est accusé d'avoir assassiné 335 Italiens,
exécutés d'une balle dans la tête.
- Des centaines d'innocents.
Certains âgés de seulement 14 ans,
ont été amenés dans une cave.
Et exécuté par Priebke.
- C'est Priebke qui a ordonné tout cela !
Il était l'un des criminels de guerre
les plus recherchés de l'histoire de Rome.
Et c'est pourtant ici même à Rome,
qu'Erich Priebke a pu obtenir son sésame,
pour partir très loin, quitter le continent
et se mettre ainsi à l'abri de toute poursuite.
Et si cela était possible, c'est donc grâce au réseau
dirigé par Alois Hudal.
Et ce n'est pas le seul nazi que l'évêque va aider.
Il y en a des dizaines d'autres parmi eux,
les plus recherchés d'Europe,
comme Adolf Eichmann, le docteur Mengele
ou Klaus Barbie.
Mais les autorités du Vatican sont-elles
au courant de tels agissements ?
Est-il possible qu'Alois Hudal ait ainsi obtenu
de faux papiers à plusieurs criminels de guerre
sans que les plus hautes sphères de l'Église
ne s'aperçoivent de rien ?
Une chose est sûre, en juin 1947,
un rapport classé top secret a révélé l'existence
de ces filières et les a signalés
au plus haut niveau.
Un rapport destiné à l'administration américaine.
L'enquête a été menée par les services secrets
des États-Unis et son contenu
fait l'effet d'une bombe.
Son titre :
"Les mouvements d'immigration clandestins en Italie."
Sur 30 pages, on y explique en détail,
comment les immigrés parviennent
à quitter l'Italie illégalement.
Et parmi ces émigrés clandestins,
le rapport pointe du doigt, les nazis allemands.
"Il y a eu et il y a encore de nombreux groupes
de nazis allemands qui viennent en Italie,
dans le seul but d'obtenir des papiers
d'identité fictifs, passeports et visas."
Mais surtout, le rapport dénonce les filières
qui aident ces clandestins.
Et parmi ces filières, c'est le Vatican qui est cité,
comme coupable numéro un.
"Le Vatican est bien sûr la plus importante
des organisations impliquées,
dans le déplacement illégal des émigrants."
Et le rapport est explicite, sur le rôle joué
par le Vatican dans l'exfiltration des nazis.
"Des recherches complémentaires indiquent
que dans les pays d'Amérique latine,
où l'Église a joué un rôle important.
Le Vatican a exercé des pressions
pour favoriser l'entrée d'anciens nazis
et d'anciens fascistes."
Le rapport liste en détail 22 filières
au sein du Vatican.
Impliquées dans ces réseaux, qui ont permis,
entre autres, aux nazis de quitter l'Europe.
Sont citées plusieurs monseigneurs,
c'est-à-dire des évêques.
Et en toute première place, on trouve,
Monseigneur Hudal.
Son adresse est indiquée,
ainsi que son numéro de téléphone.
Ce rapport des services secrets américains,
est-il remonté jusqu'au sommet du Vatican ?
Le pape de l'époque, Pie XII,
en a t il eu connaissance ?
Impossible de l'affirmer, car le Vatican refuse
encore aujourd'hui de déclassifier ses archives.
Mais pour de nombreux spécialistes,
c'est extrêmement probable.
- On n'imagine pas qu'un rapport de cette importance
n'arrive pas sur le bureau du pape.
Quand on dit le bureau du pape,
c'est vraiment le bureau du pape.
Car Pie XII, à cette époque-là,
n'a pas de secrétaire d'État.
En temps normal, ces rapports arrivent
sur le bureau du secrétaire d'État.
C'est-à-dire du Premier ministre du Vatican.
Là justement, à cette époque,
il n'y a pas de secrétaires d'État.
Donc le rapport arrive exactement sur le bureau.
- L'Italie allait peut-être devenir communiste,
après les élections.
La situation était donc très délicate,
car si le communisme gagnait du poids politique
dans le pays, cela serait la pire situation
pour l'Église catholique.
Donc, que faire ?
Que ce soit pour des raisons politiques
ou idéologiques,
des centaines de nazis ont pu se procurer
un passeport et échapper aux alliés,
grâce à des complicités au sein de l'Église.
Et une fois le précieux document en main,
certains de ces criminels fugitifs
vont trouver un refuge.
Il s'agit d'un état, où l'on met tout en œuvre,
pour qu'il soit en sécurité
et puisse échapper à la traque des alliés.
Des centaines d'entre eux vont y être accueillis,
comme Priebke, Klaus Barbie ou Eichmann.
Cet État se trouve à 12 000 km de l'Italie,
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique.
C'est l'Argentine.
L'Argentine, un pays où ils vont se sentir
comme chez eux.
Il suffit de se rendre dans les écoles
pour s'en rendre compte.
En plein milieu de l'Amérique du Sud,
on trouve des classes entières de petites têtes blondes.
Car depuis le XIXᵉ siècle, l'Argentine est une terre
d'immigration très prisée des Allemands.
En 1945, ils sont déjà près de 240 000,
attirés par l'économie florissante du pays.
Et une partie de cette population adhère
aux idées du 3ᵉ Reich.
Faisant même d'Hitler une idole.
C'est donc le pays idéal, où se réfugier
pour des criminels nazis.
D'autant que l'homme le plus puissant du pays,
le président argentin lui-même,
va leur offrir son hospitalité et sa protection.
Juan Peron est un dictateur à la main de fer
et il voue depuis des années,
une grande admiration au régime fasciste européen.
- Il admirait Mussolini.
Il a essayé de copier certaines mesures fascistes,
pour les appliquer en Argentine.
Pas celles qui étaient agressives,
mais plutôt les mesures sociales.
Il admirait également la culture allemande
et surtout l'armée allemande.
Et c'est justement le savoir-faire de l'armée
allemande, que Juan Peron convoite.
Car il a une obsession, il veut moderniser son pays
et son armée par tous les moyens.
Alors, il ne va pas hésiter à accueillir sur son sol
des milliers d'Allemands en fuite,
dont beaucoup de nazis.
- Peron voulait des nazis parce qu'ils pensaient
que beaucoup d'entre eux avaient le genre
de connaissances techniques qui lui permettraient
de développer de nouvelles armes de guerre
et une nouvelle forme d'industrie.
Alors Juan Peron va mettre en place un système
extrêmement organisé pour exfiltrer les nazis,
depuis l'Europe, sous le nez des Alliés.
Tout se passe au sein même
de deux consulats argentins,
celui de Berne en Suisse,
et celui de Gênes, en Italie.
Les fugitifs nazis n'ont qu'à présenter
de faux passeports comme ceux fournis
avec la complicité de l'Église,
pour que l'Argentine accorde rapidement
un visa en bonne et due forme.
- C'était une entreprise sponsorisée par l'État,
pour aider ces gens à fuir.
Ce n'était pas juste
une petite entreprise criminelle.
C'était une politique gouvernementale qui permettait
de faire traverser l'Atlantique aux nazis.
Grâce à des filières comme celle-ci.
Ce ne sont pas moins de 5000 nazis
qui ont émigré en Argentine.
À leur arrivée, ils se sont construits une nouvelle
vie sous la protection du président Péron.
Certains devront tout de même rendre compte
de leurs crimes, comme Adolf Eichmann
qui 10 ans après son arrivée en Argentine,
a été enlevé par les services secrets israéliens, en 1960,
puis jugé, condamné à mort et pendu en Israël.
Ou encore, comme Erich Priebke, qui a passé
près de 50 ans en Argentine,
sous l'identité d'un directeur d'école,
avant d'être extradé par la justice italienne
et condamné en 1998 à la réclusion à perpétuité.
Mais ces cas restent rares.
La majorité des criminels nazis cachés en Argentine
ont vécu tranquillement jusqu'à la fin de leurs jours,
sans jamais être inquiétés.
C'est le cas notamment de Von Alvensleben,
qui s'est reconverti dans l'élevage de poissons.
Il est mort à l'âge de 69 ans, impuni.